Speaker 1: . Let's go next to Jill from
Burbank, California. Jill, you were on the air.
Jill from Burbank, California, please unmute
yourself and then we'll be able to hear you.
Speaker 3: Hey, can you hear me? Yes. OK. Big
Fan. Two things I wanted to talk about. One was
Jesse Lee Peterson. It was fascinating to watch
you debate him, but my point is that he doesn't
think that he's wrong after even though you
confronted him. And, you know, basically showed
him that he isn't she doesn't know anything about
his stance, right? What do you think we should do
to people like that? Because should we even
engage? Because he's the the biggest example,
I think for people, even after you show them
the facts and tell them that he, you know,
they have no stance. They go and they have a
they have their show and they have their own.
Day to day and they continue. Yeah, I
Speaker 1: don't think it's so much about
embracing Jesse Lee Peterson, it's more is it
worth doing so that maybe people in the audience
see how quickly his assertions fall apart and
crumble? I don't go in thinking the goal here is
to convince Jesse Lee Peterson to change his mind.
It's let's just show how silly and cartoonish his
entire perspective is, you know, so I think it's
just we have to manage what the expectation is. I
wasn't I wasn't trying to change his mind.
Speaker 3:
Right. Yeah. But I mean, you had
one person come back and say, Oh,
I'm I'm a Democrat now and, you know,
not a Republican anymore, which is,
which is a good thing, I think maybe, yeah, that
Speaker 1: where people saw it and maybe they
changed their minds as a result of seeing it. For
sure. I think that's really the goal. It's for the
audience rather than for Jesse Lee Peterson.
Speaker 3: But now in the Tuesday election,
you know that, you know, young can win. I think
it was. Few things like the CERP, which is not
taught anywhere, but they may made a boogeyman
out of nothing, just like Trump did out of a
carrot in a caravan is coming and he tried to do
it in the midterms as well. But what do you think?
Like, why can't Democrats also make a
boogeyman out of something that Republicans do?
Speaker 1: It's just not clear Democrats would
fall for it. Like, what would they? What would
they do? What would they do? Oh, Republicans
want to ban abortion? Well, it's like most of
them do. It's it's not. You know what? Like what
would you? What would the boogeyman be, you know?
Speaker 3: Anything like that,
yeah, exactly like abortion or, um,
you know, our child care that we are basically at
the end of the list on and off and in the world.
It just doesn't seem to create so many points.
Speaker 1: It doesn't seem to create the fear
and anger that motivates these Republicans to
get out and vote. Let me think about whether
there is such an issue. It's an interesting
idea, Jill, but I just don't know if it would
work. Let me think about it.
Speaker 3: Those are the two,
thank you. Keep on doing what you're doing.
I'm going to switch from Dwight to you. My
twitch sob. Oh, thank you so much for everything.
Speaker 1: All right. Thanks, Jill. Appreciate it.
There's Jill from Burbank. Very, very strongly
presenting a number of different arguments